over the past few years Bill Burrs put
together a very respectable acting
resume making guest appearances in shows
like Breaking Bad in the Mandalorian as
well as creating his own Animated Series
F is for family but due to some dire
onset circumstances this new movie
required Bill Burr to step into an
all-new role for the first time in his
career filming for old dads started
during the pandemic in 2020 and every
major director was booked up without a
director the entire project was in
Jeopardy and in order to not lose the
opportunity for this movie to get made
altogether Bill Burr had to step in and
save the day making his director debut
strictly out of necessity the level of
work that directing as I had no I had no
idea like you have to answer every
single question like this is when I knew
I was in trouble there was one scene
like uh our set director right lovely
person she comes up to me she goes okay
in this scene there's going to be a
barbecue and I'm like yeah all right
cool and she goes what are we thinking
paper plates I'm like yeah yeah paper
plates and she goes what kind of paper
plates and I was just saying